so let's get this question out of the
way use you still believe that there is
a role for traditional philanthropy that
impact investing the business model of
working through the market is not the
way that we're going to change the world
exclusively don't believe so no it's all
that no it's not that I don't believe
that but i think that m i think that
what what impact is that investing is
saying is that there is a mobile i don't
know if i would say that works there is
a model that we are trying and that we
are developing as a community that
essentially says with investment dollars
and the commercial rigor that hopefully
accompanies those dollars one can access
issues of affordability quality access
choice availability of key goods and
services for lower-income groups in a
way that is perhaps more sustainable
because the long-term viability and
durability of the company in question is
safeguarded because it grows with our
capital and and hopefully lasts whereas
there's always this question or when
does the philanthropy run out either
because of fatigue or not on the on the
part of the giver or because that model
is no longer possible or sustainable for
whatever reason I mean is it life
support